welcome to this video playing Ian
cassoulet well it's got a high rating at
the moment I mean he's always kind of
decently rated but 24 is high he was on
26 at one time that's kind of kind of
crazy okay we get an English opening
here with your Sicilian we should be
seven that's kind of weird what that's
playable I don't believe it and that
shouldn't be playable should always be a
pawn actually at the end this kind of
this kind of thing
yeah it looks like idea I can or i can
take on take on b7 and now as well let's
see what exactly Bishop e7 r should
twist not enough on 97 not sure about it
might be seven is actually nice i have
95 in the mix
yeah it's just a pawn kind of weird this
is a very well-known tactic you cannot
really i mean this is this kind of she
is this is just shaky with 9085 so it
was surprising that he allowed it hmm
what does this reply on Knight a5 really
curious about that isn't this just
winning an exchange what is the idea
Bishop f6 on and I don't know let's just
do it and then he wants IE once Bishop
f5 at the end of it that's no big deal I
mean I'm a pawn and an exchange up so
Bishop f5 it's no problem oh it is a
problem a little bit at least I was
thinking ashes i can just retreat the
bishop but it's a whole row pain so i
actually have to play this one checking
f5 and a five so okay given the choice i
will take the bishop or is them no
there's no no reason to do it otherwise
sortie 396 Luke c5 checking the weakness
it's really just an exchange
black resilience yeah I just went into
this into this opening motif the whole
move waters a bit strange I mean if he
wants to play d5 you should do so now
this is just a regular I mean here's the
first moment where this motive is coming
up we should be seven is not working due
to this he has to play night to be six
or this is what they all play that same
and then we should be seven castles and
he basically went for this in Adelaide
way here d 5 it's kind of weird you can
probably come out of it a little bit
better than he did but I don't know
cakes that's all forced computer
actually suggests to go for this
position which is really just a pawn
down for absolutely nothing it's even a
pretty I mean if you were down upon you
want development edge and and ideally
some weaknesses to exploit but here
what's position is without any
weaknesses I'm not quick in development
that's true i have to i need one or two
sorry one or two moves like d3e bishop
out but that's really strong in champion
strange nine takes then yes it's
basically over him I was actually
overlooking event yeah I was actually
overlooking that it's a whole row cane
initially I kind of thought okay drop
the bishop back takes rook takes but as
a bishop on c1 but i have i have would
be five and and here's really just over
yeah this is this night takes a five is
a is a motif worth remembering it it
pops up in many openings where there is
a fee and shadow the center is simply
not stable black needs exactly one move
to be stable if if I would play this is
a mistake of course because that can
take
five but just to compare if he has the
bishop PA OSS is protected and the
tactic is not working so it's always
important to check for tactical strikes
against a somewhat liable center yeah
thanks for watching